the president met with Senator Paul in
the White House to discuss his agenda
for this Moscow trip and approved the
letter of introduction Paul gave to
Putin and the White House is drafting an
executive order that may impose
sanctions if someone has found a foreign
national that is guilty of meddling in
the midterm elections asked for these
sanctions glad there could be another
round in 90 days if Russia doesn't take
steps to verify it will not use these
kinds of weapons again so major let me
ask you this president Trump's legal
team has responded the special counsel
molars proposal for a presidential
interview what do we know about their
counteroffer well I just spoke to Rudy
Giuliani the president's lead attorney
on this and he now describes himself as
more optimistic than he's been in weeks
and there can be a resolution that could
lead to an interview between President
Trump and the special counsel Robert
Muller apparently the two sides have
narrowed their differences over what can
and can't be asked and Giuliani told me
that there's at least a 50/50 chance
that that interview could happen sooner
rather than later
all right major Garrett thank you very
much